- Now today we're gonna be
discussing the three pillars of
success with a
very special guest.
Someone that
I've worked with before
at a couple of our events.
He's really changed the game in
so many different industries.
I won't try and
introduce you myself but
Gary welcome to the show.
- Thanks for having me.
I'm excited to be here.
- So Gary, you've got a
really interesting background.
I think obviously
moving into the U.S.
The baseball cards,
the Wine Library.
Perhaps for some of the
people that aren't familiar with
yourself, can you give an intro?
- You know, it's fun.
Right now, I'm very much
known as a marketing guy,
a social media guy but the truth
is at the end the day and it's
why I really wanted to do
this today is I'm
a sales guy, right?
I mean from the age of
five with lemonade and I mean
five lemonade stand
franchise, really doing sales.
To the core of my adolescence
which was be a poor student but
sell pencils and erasers and
bubblegum and then ultimately
because I'm a 41-year-old male
and baseball cards were a huge
phenomenon in America, I was
selling baseball cards at
12, 13, 14, 15 and
making thousands of dollars
a weekend selling
baseball cards but it was sales.
- Right.
- It was sales and
then my dad saved all
his money as a
Russian immigrant.
You mentioned
I wasn't born in the U.S.
and bought a small
liquor store in Springfield,
New Jersey and my
late teens, early 20s
were about hand selling wine.
You know you come in for Santa
Margarita Pinot Grigio and
I'm gonna try to sell you the
Pinot Grigio we make more money
on that we think is better.
So that has been the constant.
I actually think
branding and marketing is sales.
It's just top
of the funnel work.
We were just talking
about that before camera.
The book, the new
TV show I'm doing,
it's all sales at the end of day
and so I'm an entrepreneur
for everybody who's watching.
Built a very large e-commerce
wine business in the late '90s,
early 2000's
called WineLibrary.com.
And then saw the world changing.
Was using email marketing,
Google AdWords,
banner retargeting and then
ultimately YouTube as sales and
marketing funnels
for my wine store.
YouTube sells for
$2 billion, 1.7 to Google.
I think this is a big change
in the world, the internet.
I decide that my skill of
understanding consumers
can make me more money in
my quest by the
New York Jets which is my
ultimate business ambition.
And I decide to
become an investor.
My first three
investments were
Facebook, Twitter and Tumblr.
I did very well and then I
decided seven years ago to take
a step back and build a sales
and marketing machine and that
became VaynerMedia which
I started with my brother AJ
7 1/2 years ago,
almost eight years ago.
And over the last six years
we've grown from
30 to 700 employees
to $130 million agency.
Full service,
media buying, creative,
production,
planning all that work.
And and in January of this
year I created a holding company
called Vayner X with my
acquisition of PureWow,
a female modern
media company and so now
we have publishing
arm and the agency.
And at the end of
the day, all of it,
one way or the other,
gets into the sales world.
- Right.
And clearly the investments that
you've made in those different
companies, what you're
doing with VaynerMedia,
disrupting the whole media
industry in general the whole
sales world and buying world
is being completely disrupted.
Number one, from a technology
point of view there's clearly so
many technologies out there.
But then also, number two,
around the actual mindset of
that buyer and
of that salesperson.
People don't want to be sold to.
I've always found
it really interesting
you create all this content.
You put it out there for free.
And a lot of people
kind of question that.
They go, "Why would
you do that for free?"
But I'm a strong believer you
need to give these insights out
for free and ultimately
build that connection.
So for any sales
professionals watching,
where would you advise that they
start in terms of creating their
own content or
sharing their content?
Adding their
own context as well?
- Before I go directly into
the tactics of should you make a
video, should you do a written
blog post or should you do a
podcast, I think
the bigger thing is and,
I think you get this as well, is
you have to reverse engineer who
you're trying to get to.
You know if you're a
salesperson out there right now,
if you trying to get to
me and so many of you are.
I get 50, 70 bulk emails,
bulk direct messages,
bulk Twitter direct
messages, Instagram,
business cards, all sorts of
weird stuff sent in the mail,
I'm busy.
- Right.
- I'm busy and like I'm just not
interested in you selling to me
not because I don't like
you, 'cause I respect the game.
It's because I'm just busy.
It's nothing personal.
So I think the
first thing you have to do
is reverse engineer the person.
You know because I'm not in
the market to buy anything,
I'm gonna be tougher.
But if I need certain
software or if I need something,
that's a good time to attack.
- [Tim] Right.
- So I think the number one rule
of salespeople is to listen.
Know your audience.
Know what they did if
you see an M&amp;A just happen,
if you see
layoffs just happening,
if you see one of their
comp, if I see Burger King doing
something, I'm thinking what
is McDonald's think of this.
- [Tim] Right.
- So that's number one.
Number two, where
are they spending time.
I'm easy to sell to if you
realize that I'm spending time
on social networks but I'm not
gonna want you to spam me in my
direct message with
a link and no context.
You should be producing content
for me to see it in my feed.
I think to answer
question directly everybody as a
salesperson has to figure out
how to they best communicate.
Is it written word?
Is it audio? Is a video?
Is it in person?
And how do you use the
digital world in audio,
written or video form to create
the gateway drug to in person?
One thing that people are very
confused by me is I don't even
do phone call sales calls.
- Mhmmm.
- I need to see
you face-to-face.
I'm supposed be this digital
guy and I need to see you.
I use digital and I use
all my content on YouTube,
Facebook, Instagram,
Snapchat, LinkedIn,
Medium as gateway drugs to this.
- Mhmmm.
- So I think anybody who's a
salesperson whether entre,
if you're an entrepreneur or
startup and you're not producing
content at scale,
podcast, video blog,
blog posts,
random Twitter, Facebook,
Instagram, YouTube
clips then you're losing.
That is unacceptable in 2016.
That is losing DNA.
If you are not producing content
for social networks and the
mobile device and the
platforms on it,--
- [Tim] Right.
- you basically don't exist.
- Sometimes a lot of people may
try a new initiative and then
they don't give
immediate reaction and
they think it's a failure.
- [Gary] That's right.
- And I want to go
back to your YouTube videos
with the Wine Library,
you know, you had so
much content out there,
how did you stick in there?
How did you keep
yourself motivated?
- Because I believe
in my strategies and
I'm patient as shit.
All great stuff, especially
when you're innovating,
doesn't happen right away.
This notion that
like, "Oh Gary I tried it.
"I spent 500
bucks on Facebook ads.
"It doesn't work."
Well, what if your video sucked?
What if your
product and service sucks?
I tend to do things
that are very early.
That has been my career.
When I do
things I believe in them.
I stick with them
based on intuition.
Even though for 18 months nobody
watched my wine videos at all,
I knew it was right.
I was right.
There's been
things I've done that
I jumped off a very quickly.
I started the
GaryVee app, VeeChat.
V-E-E like WeChat,
I thought it was funny,
for my fans.
Great CRM one-on-one.
Didn't feel right
after a week or two.
Spent plenty of
money building it.
Knew, stopped it
stopped after, you know,
couple months.
Wine Library TV, five
years, every day YouTube.
Decided to change
it to Daily Grape.
Insular app,
you could buy stuff.
Subscription for reviews.
It was a lot of fun.
Only did it for five months.
Stopped it 'cause it
didn't feel right any more.
- Okay.
- It's always hard to know
when to jump off something new.
But I find that people don't
believe in what they're doing.
They here a guru and they do it
begrudgingly because their boss
wants then to or
they're like,
"Well, Gary's right a
lot. So let me do it,"
but they don't believe
it and so then they jump.
They're looking for
no's instead of yeses.
Everything I do,
every business development,
every event I do, every time
I try a new marketing tactic or
sales tactic,
I'm looking for the yes.
- Right.
- I'm looking for the
yes and if the no punches me,
well then I'm like crap.
The no punched me.
I believe the majority of people
when they try new tactics are
looking for the no.
- [Tim] Mhmmm.
- And you're gonna get a lot
of subtle noes immediately.
- [Tim] Right.
- And so, I think
that's why that happens.
- And you mentioned a guru.
I know you met up
with Tony Robbins,
the other day.
He also did that
great Netflix documentary,
"I Am Not Your Guru."
- [Gary] Yes.
- Other than the fact that he
cursed and you were extremely
grateful for that, it was really
interesting just hearing the
dialogue between the
two of you because again,
to your point, people look at
these gurus or thought leaders
and then maybe try
something and then just go,
"It doesn't work,"
and then blame you for it.
- Yeah, I mean,
honestly, like I don't even.
The good news for me is I'm not
selling my audience anything so
I have very, very good vibes
with my community because when
you're not selling them
anything it's really easy.
You don't get really blamed.
- [Tim] Mhmmm.
- They may have a
judgment call on your stuff
doesn't work and that's fine.
I think that a lot of people
that are watching this right now
don't have the talent to achieve
what they want to achieve.
- [Tim] Mhmmm.
- Know how many people I've
met that wanted to be great
salespeople and I can, you
know, if you're a salesperson,
you can smell other salespeople.
You know it's like
dogs sniffing each other.
It's not super confusing to me
and I'm like you're not gonna be
a salesman or shit you're
gonna be a great salesman.
- [Tim] Mhmmm.
- Being a thought leader or
having a personal brand or doing
the self-promotion
or this and that,
it's part of my world but it's
really something I spend very
little time thinking
about, I'm an operator.
The GaryVee thing
is my side hustle.
- [Tim] Right.
- I'm running a very
large organization and company.
I'm very empathetic and I try to
be very frank with my audience.
I have a piece of content that's
really on the verge of huge
virality where I spoke to a
22-year-old on my #AskGaryVee
Show the other day
for like 20 minutes.
Really dug in with her.
She was really great and it was
very real and
the reality is is that
a stunning amount of people
behind that camera right now are
not gonna be successful in sales
'cause they're not willing to
work hard enough.
- Mhmmm.
- They love the automation.
They love your product.
- Right.
- You guys do great.
They love all these tools.
The problem is if you have the
greatest hammer and the greatest
screwdriver and
the greatest wrench,
the greatest in front of you.
- [Tim] Mhmmm.
- If you don't
use them properly,
you will lose.
- [Tim] Right.
- If there's a nail that I have
to put in the ground but I take
the wrench and I hit it when
the hammer was right there,
it still comes down
to the practitioner.
- Mhmmm.
- And you have to
be good at your craft
and you have to love...
If you don't love sales,
if you don't love it,
you have no chance
'cause it's so hard.
It's so painful.
There's so much rejection.
- [Tim] Right.
- So those are the
things I think about.
So technology clear
enabler as you've just said.
- [Gary] Yes.
- The person is
equally important--
- [Gary] More important.
- Right and going back to--
- More important.
I apologize for
jumping in but let me
make it perfectly straight.
If I go play Roger Federer right
now in tennis and I have the
greatest tennis
racket ever made.
Like taken from the
Mars' new like resources.
- [Tim] Right.
- And he took a John
McEnroe 1974 tennis racket,
he would whip my ass.
I'm crushing salespeople
that have every Salesforce,
every one of your
competitors, 37 features,
upgraded, went to
every pro conference,
watching this.
I will beat their ass in
sales every day of the week.
- [Tim] Right.
- Pure talent.
- Right. So Gary, look,
we're nearly up on time.
Would love any closing
thoughts from you for
sales professionals,
whether at a startup,
at an enterprise.
What should they go
out and do today, tomorrow?
- I look at
sales very differently
than the far majority.
I think way too many
salespeople are inpatient.
salespeople are transactional.
I think way too many salespeople
are lowest common denominator.
Spam, blast LinkedIn,
email bulk,
business card,
business card, business card.
So I think I've got a
different tactic on sales.
- Mhmmm.
- But don't get it
twisted, it's what I am.
If you're not
happy with your upside,
if you are not fully fulfilled.
I think a lot of what
you heard from me today,
I'm doing things
were reverse of you.
I think a lot of you are doing
things that are directly in
front of you.
Numbers that they
put in front of you,
you're trying to achieve that
because you have a beach house
you want to buy or
go on that vacation.
Sales is a funny game if
you work in a big company.
They manipulate
numbers to create your actions.
I believe that the best
salespeople are doing things in
a different way.
I think you need to care
about the customer for real,
reverse engineer them and give
them what they need and so
I have a funny
feeling that for 87.9%,
arbitrary number, that 87.9% of
the people watching right now,
I'm a better salesperson
than you because I'm the
anti-salesperson and I think
that's the best salesperson.
Think about that.
Think about how you give
yourself air cover to not do
behavior that is short-term.
Please understand that the world
has changed and the attention of
the person you're
trying to get to is
moving into different places.
And this big one.
Stop complaining.
Salespeople aren't
allowed to complain.
The market is the market.
Your bosses are your bosses.
A great salesperson shuts their
mouth and she goes to work every
day and tries to bring value to
the end-user and is patient and
over time wins
the marathon of sales.
Put yourself in that position.
("Unbreakable" by Ben Katz)